remembering for these men isn't just on
anniversaries or when their stories told
like now in the HBO Sky Atlantic series
Chernobyl and focus turns just for one
moment to what the miners of Tula did
there the reactor fuel is going to sink
into the ground and poison the water
from Kiev to the black sea all of it yet
we now move points out those of his
friends who've died he led the second
group of miners to go from two-level in
Kirkuk automatic of a bullet award
Nakano guerrilla durable rugged board
there are some Eklutna dismiss
initiative Chernobyl so what's the job
we need to install a liquid nitrogen
heat exchanger underneath this concrete
pad and once above the pad the core of
the nuclear reactor which is melting
down like potentially on 26th of April
1986 a reactor at the Chernobyl nuclear
power plant in what was then Soviet
Ukraine had exploded leaking mersive
amounts of deadly radiation
firefighters nuclear scientists and the
military which rafted in to try and
contain the spread the miners job to dig
a tunnel beneath the melting core of the
nuclear reactor and stop it from seeping
into the water table
jae-min noted little capital organic Oh
Lugosi
study said metal fragment vcruz it is
not not yet a curve ball snicker Donnie
vigil incredible she knew this Navaratri
Bush the quota issues motion they like
the series they like the Soviet jokes
but they're not completely sold on the
details we head with andreas own off to
his old mine near Tula to a soundtrack
of songs he's written about Chernobyl in
the end the molten core of the reactor
cooled down by itself
the heat exchanger they'd installed was
never even turned on but one in four of
the miners has died in the year since
pierre-yves you a blood no natural
probably Watsa a mini vanilla swirl
roberto talking about the Hoosiers here
in unum talk resorts to Nippon our
beautiful this memorial wall was built
three years ago to commemorate the 30th
anniversary of Chernobyl and the names
of the dead at that point came up to
here these four slates were all left
blank but in the last three years you
can see they filled up
it's in front of a school so the
children know the sacrifice of the
liquidators the 600,000 men and women
who worked to contain the nuclear spill
occurred my caronian he was 2 PI / Minka
yada push signal value on both talking
career come on the Alta Cooper stupid
really grouchy
Kotori new noggin luteum with our
richness to it a Nidoran is Amelia yeah
tornador humanism Katya we do it there
are a few colonists in Russia who've
called the series American propaganda to
discredit Russia's nuclear expertise the
miners don't see it that way they're
glad for the attention they're glad
their sacrifice is known to Martha Magna
Sky News Tula Russia